foreign
Fitness is for Life Fitness is not a
destination it's a journey being fit and
healthy is not a part-time hobby it's a
lifestyle so I started this channel
almost 10 years ago that's right can you
believe it let me know in the comments
below how long have you been following
my channel if you're new and you haven't
yet subscribed then be sure to hit the
Subscribe button when I first started
this channel I was rather new in Fitness
I only started exercising about two
years and so I was still learning a lot
about Fitness and Nutrition as well as
understanding my own body and through
all these years each and every one of
you have been on this journey with me
and grew together with me so fast
forward to today I've been exercising
consistently for more than 10 years now
I can proudly say that Fitness is my
lifestyle and it is still a journey I'm
on so how did I get to this point of
making exercising part of me in this
video I'll be sharing with you some of
my tips on how to stay motivated stay
consistent and build in long-term
Fitness lifestyle not just today but
forever
the most common mistake which people
fall into is that they go to the extreme
and try to jump in and do everything
change their diet start exercising stop
drinking Etc and just within a couple of
weeks it becomes unsustainable or they
lost motivation and fall back into their
old ways of living what we do on a daily
basis is based on our habits habits run
our daily life and it's built through
many years of doing the same thing over
and over again whether it's eating junk
Foods overeating or giving yourself
excuses for not exercising therefore in
order to build a new positive habit it
will take time as well so I didn't just
start exercising 10 years ago and
maintained that momentum ever since my
first two to three years of Fitness were
very inconsistent with a lot of
uncertainty what I've learned from those
years is to start with simple goals and
you don't have to set high expectations
for yourself when you set extreme goals
you're more likely to feel defeated if
you mess up when the expectations aren't
as intense you're more likely to stay
consistent and enjoy your journey you
don't put that much pressure on yourself
to be perfect if you eat something bad
or you skip a workout session you wake
up the next day and get right back on
track because now it's just part of your
lifestyle so this approach is much more
attainable and leads to more consistency
long term
mental strength involves developing
daily habits that build mental muscle it
also involves giving up bad habits that
hold you back most of the time what
stops us from getting a workout done is
our mental strength you're constantly
fighting with yourself mentally and
giving yourself excuses on why you
should skip your workout today so when I
find this happening to me instead of
letting the thoughts continue to run in
my head I would be aware of the thoughts
block them off and immediately get my
workout done I would exercise my mental
muscle and tell myself that working out
regularly helps make it a more
sustainable Behavior whereas missing
sessions doesn't I would also remind
myself how good I will feel physically
and mentally after a workout session so
the more I practice and exercise my
mental strength in doing what's right
for me the easier it becomes to shut off
those negative thoughts and bad habits
and over time I've built up mental
resilience discipline and a long-term
Fitness habit so remember it doesn't
happen overnight you have to keep
exercising your mental muscle
oftentimes we're so obsessed with
setting fitness goals and achieving them
that we've forgotten about the process
remember sustainable results take time
nothing good comes easy be patient when
it comes to reaching your physical goals
but more importantly I wanted you to
start focusing on the journey and learn
to fall in love with the process and the
person you become through the Journey
are you enjoying how much energy you
have nowadays are you feeling happier
and more fulfilled are you able to
manage your anxiety and depression
through exercise are you having more
confidence in yourself
are you feeling stronger physically and
mentally are you loving how you feel and
look
so check in with yourself and ask
yourself these questions regularly by
looking deep within yourself you'll be
able to find the joy in exercising and
also a meaningful reason on why feeling
good and fit should be part of your
lifestyle forever
when I first got into fitness I was
introduced to functional training but
through the years I've explored and
tried out many different types of
workouts such as group exercises
kickboxing running pole dancing yoga
hits and strength training you won't
just be interested in one type of
workout and this could even change
Through The Years so one thing that has
helped me to stay consistent and to stay
interested is to keep exploring and keep
trying new things in my fitness journey
this way I'm always learning different
things and also discovering what I might
be good at so don't be afraid to go to a
new class and try it out you might just
fall in love with it and realize how
good you are
[Music]
yup that's right you don't have to give
up on your favorite treats just to be
healthy instead find the balance to
nourish your body and soul ditch the
word dieting when we think of dieting is
often associated with restriction
short-term and unsustainable regimes
most people who have the dieting mindset
tend to gain more weight over time so
I'm a firm believer in never giving up
on the foods you love instead find the
balance in nourishing your body and soul
that means eating regular and balanced
meals that will satisfy your nutrition
and mineral needs with your Cravings so
I personally practice the 80 20 method
that means eating to nourish my body 80
of the time and eating to nourish my
soul for the remaining 20 for example
you can find a way to make your favorite
foods healthier if Pizza is your
favorite food then get creative and use
clean ingredients to make your health
version instead of enjoying the entire
slice of cake share it with a friend if
you know you're going to enjoy a buffet
then have a light lunch living a healthy
lifestyle long term is about finding
that balance which can be maintained on
a daily basis
I have one simple rule which could be
applied to any Fitness activity I do not
allow myself to go on more than three
days without a workout so if I know I'll
be having a busy couple of days coming
up or if I'm going for a holiday soon I
would make sure to fit in my workouts
before so I have banked my three days
even if I'm on a holiday with no gym
access I'll still make sure to keep my
holiday and active one by clocking in my
steps if you can keep to this one simple
rule you'll be able to make Fitness part
of you forever and you will never have
to struggle with trying to get back on
track I've stuck to this rule for more
than 10 years now and I would say this
is one of the most important rule for me
to make Fitness a lifestyle
look at transforming your workout
routine into a long-term habit as a
journey and throughout the journey
remember to listen to your body and your
mind and trust that you will achieve
what you set out to do in the end a
positive mind frame will take you
halfway to your goal remember that
Journeys don't necessarily go to plan
and that it can be difficult to keep a
positive mindset all the time so if
you're having a low day or if you're
lacking in motivation accept it and go
with it take a day off if you need and
remember that tomorrow is another new
day don't get discouraged if you stop
for a while get started again gradually
and work up your old Pace even if you
don't meet your goals today or tomorrow
pick yourself back up and move forward
as long as you wake up every day and try
to be better than you were yesterday you
are on the right track remember physical
activity is for life when you start to
view health and fitness as a lifestyle
rather than a part-time hobby or a
30-day challenge you develop behaviors
that will improve many areas of your
life living a healthy lifestyle can
Inspire creativity and teach you
discipline adaptability and balance this
will not only leave you feeling and
looking better but you will show up as a
better version of yourself for the
people in your life that truly matter so
remember to review these tips whenever
you feel like your motivation is
sleeping if you enjoyed this video If
you find this video to be useful then be
sure to give this video a thumbs up and
don't forget to also hit the Subscribe
button what other mindfulness or mindset
tips would you like to learn more let me
know in the comments below and don't
forget to check out my YouTube channel
for a lot more workout videos healthy
recipes nutrition tips as well as
mindset tips and I will see you next
time all the best